journaling is an extremely powerful way
of pouring out everything that you have
in your mind on paper no editing no
sensoring if I get a swear word I'm
writing a swear word there there's
tremendous power and potential in taking
this out now imagine if the phone were
on your hand and you were just not able
to take it off at all even after
journaling imagine if somebody else puts
a palm down there and shares that burden
along with you now you're rest is taking
half of the weight and somebody else is
taking half of that weight that is the
power of confiding opening your heart
sharing your troubles with somebody and
seeking help the one thing that I always
love to say we don't have to struggle
alone there is help available if we seek
it seek and thou shal find knock and the
door shall open hey it's EV car Michael
and I make these videos because I need
them because being around successful
entrepreneurs who are pushing who are
driving who are doing amazing things
gives me that that extra little
motivational inspirational boost in the
morning every day to help me go off and
accomplish great things too and I hope
that this video gives you that
inspiration as well so today let's get
some incredible motivation from the one
and only gor gal
[Music]
Das as soon as you are up every single
day number one begin your day with
gratitude don't just charge your phones
watches tablets or laptops the first
thing in the morning
charge yourself up as well with
positivity that will last you all day
and the most powerful of all positive
emotions that'll make you feel empowered
is gratitude because it forces you to
shift your attention to your blessings
than to your problems which are anyways
going to be an integral part of all of
our Lives second resolve to have a
positive Vision nobody including
ourselves is perfect everybody has a
good and a not so good side to them and
the tendency of the mind is to look at
the not so good side every morning
resolve that you'll try and look at the
positive side of people and neglect or
deal with the dark side because the more
we focus on the negative our mind
becomes occupied with others BS ruining
our work our day our peace our joy and
even our relationships slow
down not in terms of achieving not in
terms of work okay but in terms of life
I think there's a need to slow down a
little bit because we are not human
doings we are human beings right doing
is a very important aspect of our life
but being is equally or more important
to empower our are doing if we don't
enter into the space of being our doing
is a mad
rush we need to feel empowered to deal
with that rush so we're not just human
doings we human beings and when we learn
to slow down we enter into the space of
being and in that space of being in that
space of Silence we are able to listen
to our own
voice the problem is the noise outside
is drowning us the noise of immediate
emergencies the noise of taxes to pay
the noise of competition around the
noise of public opinion the noise of
social media which is drowning us and we
just not able to be in syn with our own
voice so when we slow down a little bit
and enter into that space of being in
that space of Silence just to be able to
spend some time with our own selves we
are able to slowly tune into our own
voice listen to our own voice you know
when I upgraded my career to be a life
coach I was an electrical engineer
working with hiet peard and here I was
suddenly moving out of my white colored
H Packard job to be a monk living in an
ashram in a monry trying to be what is
called as a life coach and back then
nobody even knew that word really you
know and I was wondering so many of my
friends who studied with me at
University who were with me at he peard
have way up there you know many of them
are CEOs and directors of leading
multinational corporations in the
Silicon Valley I was wondering how am I
going to cope with this fear of missing
up foro you know and here's what I
learned as a monk from the ancient
spiritual Heritage of this country
India I learned the art of focusing on
myself and my my self-development the
more my attention is focused on others
I'm always going to think of what I'm
missing out I'm missing out on the nice
car he or she has I'm missing out on the
nice looks he or she has I'm missing out
on the nice vacation he or she has when
I focus on others the only emotion I'll
go through is I am missing something in
life on the other hand if I learn to
focus on myself I'm not going to looking
be looking at what I'm missing out I'm
going to be looking at what I'm being
blessed with the opportunities that I
have the more I focus on myself the more
I focus on self-development I'm not
going to be a victim of the fear of
messing up and the problem with social
media today is we've made everybody's
private life public so you're sitting
here in Mumbai and you're looking at a
friend of yours having a great time in
Singapore so the more you're focusing on
him in Singapore you're not going to be
able to relish your time in Mumbai you
have a friend who's a couple they got
married it was their wedding anniversary
and the guy posts a picture with his uh
wife you know like hugging each other
and like blah blah blah having a great
time and you're having a tough time with
your wife and man this guy is having a
great relationship I'm missing out on
the great relationship idiot that's
idiocy because you don't even know that
that guy and the lady who posted a
picture of such a romantic uh gesture
with each other had a horrible fight
that afternoon ladies and gentlemen we
can only deal with this for more
mentality effectively if we shift our
attention and focus from others to
ourselves this is how I dealt with foro
if I would have focused on my friend in
Silicon Valley I would have thought God
I'm missing something here I am a life
coach reaching out to thousands if not
Millions trying to do my bit and
completely satisfied with what I'm doing
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the moment in
your life and your business I'll see you
there Mark Twain something said
something very beautiful he said uh
there are two most important days in our
lives first is the day when we were born
and second is the day when we find out
why the day we are born is known to us
the day when we find out why is the day
when we probably start discovering our
purpose but I remember one of my visits
to London I went to one of my friends
took me to see just spend an evening at
St Paul's Cathedral we were walking in
central London walking around in fact I
think I had a house talk at the House of
Commons and I finished that talk and
after that talk we were walking around
and we came to St Falls Cathedral and I
remember meeting the priest there and
the priest there told me an incredible
story of the St Paul's Cathedral when it
was being made the architect there
probably about
1700s when he was making this Cathedral
one day he was not known to the people
who are working at the construction side
one day the architect just walked around
and was moving around to see what was
happening and he saw a brick layer
laying braks he asked the brick layer
what are you doing the man replied well
I'm laying
bricks he moved a little ahead he saw
another brick layer he said what are you
doing he said well I'm laying bricks
because I need to make money for my
family he moved a little further ahead
and he saw another third brick layer he
said what are you doing he said I've
heard that this gentleman this architect
is creating a spectacular
Cathedral and I'm trying to lay the
brick in such a way that I can help him
in making this Cathedral extremely
beautiful now you really don't change
what you do we don't change what we do
we have our jobs we have our families we
have our businesses we lead we do what
we do and we're going to have to do what
we do it's a shift of
mindset that takes us off from the work
mode to the purpose mode here was one
brick leer who was just doing his work
I'm just doing it for the heck of doing
it second one is his motivation behind
doing it was making money and
maintaining a family fine that's a part
of the purpose as well and the third
person well there's a spectacular
Cathedral being created I'm trying to
play my role in a way that I can create
an impact and make a difference it's
easy to make a buk it's hard to make a
difference and at the core of purpose is
how do we make a difference in whatever
it is that we do and leave a legacy
behind of trying and adding value to the
world that we live in we live in a world
today
where everything's very quick to form
and everything's very quick to
break we live in a world of instant
gratification yeah we live in a world
where we don't have patients to stand in
a queue to buy something because we just
order it online yeah we live in a world
where I can't wait for a coffee to get
ready because I can go and put it in a
slot machine and get a cup of
coffee there's not
patience and it's not it's not an issue
with youngsters or older people it's a
generational
issue it's a issue technology has added
so much value to our lives but it's also
taken away things from us a virtue is a
part of you and it applies to every
aspect of your life a virtue is agnostic
it applies to any aspect of your life
positive negative both you know so I see
a lot of times that things like it's
like love at first sight and divorce at
first
fight break up at first
fight finished before marriage is like
roses are red and the sky is blue you're
my sweetheart I love you kind of stuff
and after a while its roses are dead and
I am blue you're my headache I'll kill
you you can
imagine there's no you know patience to
work on it when you when you when you
grow a plant when you grow a plant it
takes patience to se the seed you have
to nurture it you to use right kind of
fertilizers you to water it before it
starts bearing fruits of flowers a
relationship is like a plant can't
expect it to happen overnight can't
expect it to happen in 6 months or 8
months or 10 months it's a journey and
it takes a while for a bonding to form
it takes a while for that respect to
develop the connection of your soul your
soulmate is not about some physical
stuff physical stuff is a consequence of
that being a soulmate it's not the
purpose of being a soulmate yeah but
over a period of time believe me you the
heart starts yearning for companionship
I feel that this world is like a
university and you come to an come to a
university to get
educated you come to a university to
enhance your knowhow you come to a
university to learn you come to a
university to deepen your understanding
about the subject you come to a un
University to get a degree to to
graduate and start something right in
the outside world to me this world seems
to be like University right it's all
about learning it's all about evolving
it's all about going through the process
of enhancing my understanding and
educating myself in
life now imagine a life where everything
was fair what's the
learning imagine a life when everything
goes exactly the way you want it what
the bloody hell am I
learning imagine a life where I get what
I want when I want how I want where is
my
Evolution do I even have an opportunity
to work on myself and everything goes my
way when you go to the gym you lift
weights you're lifting weights Against
Gravity because you lift weights Against
Gravity is when your muscles grow grow
growth is a consequence of going against
gravity and going against gravity means
suffering right if I put a weight down
bloody hell no problem it's just going
down there's no pain in it but if I have
to put pick up a dumbbell which is 25
kilos up like this is going
anti-gravity and anti-gravity means pain
but pain means growth right pain means
growth now some people will take have to
go through that pain and because they're
going through that pain just for the he
of going through it there's no
growth look at people going to the gym
and just swinging without focusing on
their muscle there's no growth they're
just swinging the muscle's not even
lifting the way there's no mind muscle
connection you know but those who are
not just going through it for the heck
of it they see the pain they know that's
anti-gravity they know there are issues
they know their problems they know their
challenges and when they consciously try
to use it for their growth that is when
growth
happens no pain pain no gain there's no
question of growth without pain you go
to university it's hell of a lot of pain
to go through thick fat books to write
the assignments to go through the wers
to write your
exams you have to Slug It Out like hell
if you want a degree from IV league
university go to I Ahmedabad and ask any
of the students they're slogging it
out right it's
painful but that's the purpose how do
you grow how do you evolve how do you
learn how do you progress without having
gone through that pain so to me you
could just call it this is a world of
suffering suffering suffer it's such a
negative way of looking at it and I'm
not one of those I hate looking at the
world in a very pessimistic negative way
that oh there's so much pain there's so
much there is pain undoubtedly like you
rightly said at the beginning of this
question nobody's life is perfect and it
can't be
right we're not looking for perfection
in our life we're looking for genuiness
and sincerity of commitment to our lives
right Perfection nobody can have but can
we be sincere in our life yes perfect
moments nobody can have can happy
moments can we have yes a perfect
relationship nobody can have happy
relationship we can try to have a
perfect home nobody can have a happy
home we can try to have you know so I
really don't think that like I said I
don't look at this world just constantly
saying it's pain pain pain pain pain
pain oh God sometimes spirituality and
spiritual leaders
just just bombard people with this man
people are going through enough of that
stuff you don't need to tell them that
you need to direct that energy rightly
to says how do you utilize that pain to
grow how do we maintain that state of
Happiness when I don't feel happy yeah
how many of you have had this feeling
and in the morning you're kind of kind
of okay and in the afternoon you hit
rock bottom any of you had that
feeling I thought it was just coffee you
know
the I mean we go through such a range of
emotions throughout the day right the
first thing I want to say to all of you
is please stop being overly obsessed
with being
happy there is no need to be happy all
the
time please stop being overly obsessed
with being positive there is no need to
be positive all the time please stop
overly obsessed with this thing that I
have to smile always there is no need to
smile all the time do you realize that
this pressure to be positive and happy
is making me negative and
miserable do you realize that this
pressure is
toxic when you have to be pressurized to
be positive that becomes toxic sick
positivity it's not positivity accept
your emotions with full authenticity
when I feel low it's all right to feel
low as long as I don't feel low all the
time in a chronic way if I feel low and
negative all the time I need help but if
I feel low on a daily basis someday
somebody's going to say something
somebody comes and says you look like a
hog I'm going to say smile thank you sir
for that compliment I'm going to feel
insulted I'm going to feel like I'm
rubbish I'm going to feel like I'm a
piece of trash that he's calling me a
hog you know what I mean so the first
thing guys one very important principle
stop
taking pressure problems happen
challenges happen struggles happen
issues happen misunderstandings happen
Health crisises happen Financial
crunches happen markets go down and that
happens all of that
happens
happiness doesn't
happen you have to make it happen
because right things don't
happen you have to make the right things
happen Fitness is the right thing
doesn't
happen you have to make
Fitness happen any of you want to lose
any
weight oh thank
you
others
[Music]
lose weight you know I have told one of
my friend he put on so much weight I
said by you know what he's telling
[Music]
me
[Applause]
that was his reply that guy tell
you deserve the
back losing weight doesn't happen you
have to make it happen not reacting when
you're angry shutting that Bloody mouth
up doesn't
happen you have to make it
happen up up right things don't happen
automatically only wrong things happen
automatically right things you have to
make them happen
guys they don't happen like
that one man was asking his wife when
you're like really really really angry
at me what do you do to went out your
anger on me
[Music]
he's asking his wife like really wild at
be what do you do to went out your anger
he said I clean the commode in the
house so he said why do you clean the
commode to went out your anger on me he
said I clean it with your
toothbrush so the next morning there's
some special effects in your
mouth I'm sorry I'm sorry I'll tell you
what I'll tell tell you what we all
react in our own ways she has a
toothbrush and you have your own
ways to lose
it ladies and
gentlemen not
reacting and shutting this
up doesn't
happen you have to make it
happen saying a sorry when somebody
hurts you or forgiving somebody when
somebody hurts
you doesn't
happen you have
to make it happen I'll tell you what the
nature of problems is that it consumes
our
mind imagine a tooth which is hurting I
don't if somebody's had their fingers
stuck in the edge of the door and the
door is slammed good Heavens it hurts
like hell and then the pain is just so
all consuming the mind just focuses so
much on the pain right I think it's just
the nature of problems that it draws our
mind towards them like the tongue going
towards the cumin seed in my tooth when
it was stuck it's like Gravity the law
of gravity if we put this bottle up and
put it up here and drop it it's going to
just be pulled down yeah dragged down by
the power of gravity I think there's a
power of gravity existing within us as
well they're just natural for us to be
dragged down to our issues our problems
right to everything that's negative I
think being being pulled into negativity
is so normal it's like gravity put the
bottle down it falls Stu you don't have
to do anything but if I were to pull
water up from the ground floor to the
eighth
floor I need a motor correct to work
against gravity and I need conscious
hard work to bring it there so it's so
natural for the mind to feel negative
and go to towards the problem but if I
have to look at 31 other teeth I have to
make a conscious choice to take my
tongue away right if I have to pull the
water down from the ground floor to the
eighth floor I have to put a pump to
pull it up it's not easy work it's hard
work right but hard work pays off that's
when you like look at really saying okay
this is fulfilling me now and that and
and I I definitely don't want to impose
this this principle of gratitude in
a in a unrealistic way on people because
sometimes misery is so intense
absolutely you know when troubles are
smaller you can still consciously look
at the brighter side of
life you know but sometimes troubles are
just so intense and massive and they
seem to be like mountains unmoving
unshakeable mountains they just stand
there for ages and
decades how in such a situ wouldn't it
be so
violent to forcefully impose the
principle of gratitude on a
person whose life is so acutely absorbed
in intense
misery you know I call that toxic
positivity it's
toxic it's not natural so what does one
do really yeah yeah it's just yeah in
such a situation when it's just so
overwhelmingly painful you know my take
on it is it's hard to look at the
brighter side when this intense pain
there but at the same time I also feel
if we are consumed by negativity with
that pain and that problem and occupying
our mind we lose the ability to deal
with it the way we are meant to correct
so if if we could seek help if I'm not
able to see it we could seek help of
somebody it could be professional help
or personal help friends whoever it
could be we could seek help to be able
to shift our attention to even the
tiniest things so that that little
positivity becomes the anchor to deal
with how can every morning be the same
how can every afternoon be the same how
can every evening be the same how can
every day be the
same
every day is a different day and
therefore they changed the greeting now
greeting good
morning happy
morning happy morning sir happy morning
how you doing this morning happy morning
good
morning
morning you can't say good morning
because sometimes there may be nothing
good in that morning nothing good in
that day so now the term is Happy
morning happy
morning because whether the morning is
good or not you can still choose to be
happy
right whether it's good or not cannot be
a
choice whether the morning is good or
not for you cannot be a choice it's not
a choice for you when you wake up some
virus may enter into your head and you
get up with a high fever it's not a
child you have whether the morning is
good or not is not in your control
whether the afternoon is good or not is
not in your control the evening is good
or not is not in your control whether
the day is good or not is not in your
control but whether you can be happy in
that moment well you can choose to
be when people smile it doesn't mean
things are going
good it just means that they've chosen
to smile time does
fly time has two wings and one one
Peak like a like a airplane the two
wings of the plane con time are passed
in future yesterday and tomorrow are the
two
wings and the Bonet that front Peak is
the
[Music]
present and time flies like a plane
flies don't allow that pant plane to fly
in the autopilot
mode
[Music]
time may fly but you are the pilot of
the plane you have to decide where to
take your time you have to decide where
to invest your time you have to decide
how to utilize your time otherwise time
is just flying wherever it wants
[Music]
to therefore change your vocabulary
don't say I spend my time
say I'm investing my time spend my time
inak spending means f g investment means
return return you spend you give you
invest you look for returns you say I
spent my time it's gone you see I invest
my time in my career I invested my time
in my studies I invested my study in a
Rel time in a relationship invested my
time in spirituality I invested my time
in association there is a
return there's a return
RTI return on
[Music]
investment
one of my friends used to say life is
unfair get used to it how many of you
heard that
one yeah and there's another friend of
mine who's a big businessman he said
life is unfair learn to
[Music]
negotiate two contrary statements one is
saying life is unfair get used to it
like giving in and the other saying life
is unfair
negotiate work on something which one's
right which one's wrong both are
right life is
unfair learn to live with it when things
come and you can't change it acceptance
is the only way and life is unfair learn
to negotiate solve problems and craft
your own
happiness
[Music]
right I tell you
what that is life we all have the choice
to craft our
happiness make a happy life remember if
life gives you a
cactus you don't have to sit on
it you can do what you need to do with
the cactus we can also learn to choose
to live a better life ladies and
gentlemen
life can get finished anytime before
life gets finished complete your life by
adding these values to your life secrets
of living well is what makes your a
happy
life finish
incomplet one guy asked what is the
difference between the word complete and
finished the fellow said if you find the
right partner to get married to in your
life your life is
complete if you get the wrong
one life is finished but if the right
one catches you with the wrong one life
is completely finished
guys but before life is finished let's
complete it no one in this world is
perfect we all have some shortcomings
some weaknesses some faults some flaws
we all have a good side to us but then
we also have some conditionings some bad
habits that have stayed long with us and
are hard to let go of have you ever
taken note of the spelling of the word
habit if you take the H out of it a bit
Still Remains now if you take the A out
of the remaining spelling bit
Still Remains and then if you take the B
out of the remainder it Still Remains
that's probably why they say old habits
die hard a great zen teacher named benzy
had many students one day the students
came up to their teacher benzy and
reported how they had caught one of
their fellow students red-handed as he
was stealing something in class beny
patiently heard them out but took no
action a couple of days later the same
boy was caught stealing yet again
another time and even this time the Zen
master did absolutely nothing this
annoyed all the students under him who
came up to him and protested that he
expelled this boy who was a compulsive
thief out of his school they further
threatened that if no action was taken
against the boy they would all leave the
school and then benzy could have this
thief as his only student and teach him
in peace the teacher summoned all his
students for a meeting when they had all
assembled he said to them see you're all
good boys coming from good families
you're all mature and you know what is
right and what is wrong if you leave my
school you'll have absolutely no trouble
in joining some other school what about
this brother of yours he indeed is
conditioned to stealing and I'm aware of
it he does not even know the difference
between right and wrong if I reject him
which other school will take him who
will teach him if I don't who will put
the effort to reform him if I don't I'm
really sorry but I cannot ask him to go
it's been wonderful teaching you guys
and I would love to have you continue
with me but if because of his staying
you want to leave well
who am I to stop you the students were
stunned by their teacher's answer being
touched by his compassionate nature and
inspired by the values that he held
sacred they decided to stay on and the
boy who had stolen he had tears rolling
down his eyes too the broadb mindedness
and compassion of the Zen master benzi
transformed his heart he never stole
again and his later life became
extremely renowned for his
Integrity mistakes happen wrong is done
and sometimes repeatedly rather than
labeling people as bad it's important
that we help them reform by being
sensitive and empathetic of course if
someone is hardwired to do wrong and
does not show any signs of remorse or
any signs of improvement and continues
to shamelessly abuse the goodness shown
to them such people may need to be
treated differently but in most cases
patient compassion can help people
change remember every saint has a past
and every
wrongdoer a future one of the biggest
issues with mental health today is
focusing on others lives more than our
own and trust me we have enough to be
grateful for we have enough to be happy
we have enough to make progress start
from where you are with with what you
have the way you can and you will surely
make progress we will never be able to
walk we will never able to walk unless
we focus on what we have at the moment
every single time on I'm on a plane the
one thing that I like is the
announcements that the cabin crew
members make and one of the
announcements they make is if there be a
lack of oxygen supply in the cabin
oxygen masks will come down from the
panel above your head
pull the mask sharply towards you to
start the flow of oxygen put the mask on
your face and nose and breathe
normally make
sure your
mask is in place before you can help
children infants or others and therefore
ladies and gentlemen guys and girls work
on yourself take care of yourself
prioritize these principles for yourself
and when you do that you will surely be
able able to give that in your own
capacity to people in this country and
in the world trust the broader plan tell
yourself that whatever is going to
happen today the apparent good or the
apparent bad is exactly what I need at
this point of time in my life nothing
more nothing less have complete trust
that every incident that's going to
happen throughout the day that which is
beyond your control is simply a small
part of a much larger picture that will
unfold eventually only for your good and
your well-being keep reminding yourself
of this as you confronted with
challenging situations through the day
if you want to be successful number one
is we shouldn't be goal focused we
should be process focused I see a lot of
guys go to the gym you know uh uh any of
you guys go to the gym when you go to a
gym I see these younger guys going to a
gym and doing bicep curls that's the
only exercise they focus on because
that's the way to girls show your guns
so you'll see them go to the gym I'm
going to put the microphone down for a
second even if you don't hear me it's
fine guys they'll do this and they'll
swing the biceps don't lift the weight
at all it's the B that's lifting the
weight and in the mirror they're saying
they should be isolating their biceps
and just picking their weight with the
biceps right so when your goal focused
you don't get the goal when your process
focused you reach there so whatever it
is in your life that you want to achieve
focus on the process the more consumed
You Are by the process this greater
chances you reach the goal then just
focus on on the goal and not on the
process in a very generic sense I feel
feel that when we talking about purpose
we are talking about making a difference
and you cannot make a difference in
someone's life unless you've made a
difference in your own life you can only
give others what you have if you can
make a difference to your own life then
you can lead a life of making a
difference to others and that is the
generic understanding of purpose but
when it comes to purpose in terms of
specifics this is what I feel here are
the three steps three peas again the
first thing I say is figure out what are
you good at and what do you love doing
when I can find these two things in one
that's called my passion the first P the
second PE is when my passion can pay me
that's my second P it's called my
profession my passion becomes my
profession when my passion starts paying
me the third aspect is when that
profession you have can start
contributing and making a difference in
the lives of someone Beyond a paycheck
Beyond promotions Beyond money all
that's a necessary aspect but beyond
that that's called the third P which is
our purpose so when passion pays you
that becomes your profession and
profession contributes and makes a
difference that's called your purpose
sometimes people are burning the candle
at both ends just more often than not
more often than not you know they don't
even know that they themselves need
attention and trying to cater to the
needs of the family and cater to work
goodness which neglecting our own selves
selfcare is gone back you know gone way
back and how can you pour out of an
empty
jug how do you does one pour out of an
empty jug to be able to pour out your
jug has to be full if you have to put
the oxygen mask on somebody else you
have to have your own mask in place
first you know so in that
introspection we start to find out what
is it that needs attention is it me is
it my family is it my work and balance
is a very Dynamic
principle post that once you're aware of
what needs attention is then those micro
steps to act on them a change in the
world begins with personal practice
revolutions start by individuals
adopting a certain ideology in their
lives Mahatma Gandhi said see the change
that you want to
be be the change that you want to see in
the world right extremely crucial
personally for me I live in a tiny
little space very tiny
space it's a closed
space so because it's a closed space
there's an air conditioner in my
room the only time I turn the air
conditioner on is in the night when I'm
meant to go to sleep because it's all
closed and I turn it on for a certain
time turn it off it's there's a timer
set to it all throughout the day even In
the Heat of the summer and I'm not
expecting anybody to do
this I'm telling you what I did do as a
personal practice to contribute
to the environment sust and sustainable
development goals each one of us based
on our own convenience based on our own
tolerance
levels can adopt a tiny practice doesn't
have to be any bombastic thing doesn't
have to be any big thing if I can take
one small thing up and consistently keep
doing
it imagine 1.4 billion
people making a tiny
commitment and practicing it
consistently
you know what that multiplying factor is
you know what the compounding impact is
so until there are responsible
people nothing is going to change a plum
once said oh my dear Lord can you please
make me a
banana God said why because that guy
loves
banana so God said
tastu so the plum became a
banana so then the guy came
instead he purchased
[Music]
orange God please make me an
orange so the banana got T became an
orange so the guy came picked the orange
bit him po spat
him then he said my dear Lord can you
please make me
grapes God said theast to became grapes
and the guy didn't even look at the
grapes and the grapes
said how I wish I remained a plum there
would be someone who loves a plum who
would come and take
me ladies and gentlemen we are all
[Music]
different
likes
dislikes Everyone's an
individual everyone's
[Music]
different
how many of you like
mangoes oh wow okay that's a wrong
question sorry how many of you don't
like
[Music]
mangoes there one two hands who don't
like
mangoes right just because someone likes
mangoes should have Plum become a
mango just because someone likes
plums should a mango become a plum if
you a plum remain a plum if you're a
mango remain a mango if you are an apple
remain a if you are a guaa remain a guaa
you are created to be a guaa one of the
things that I was taught when I joined
the ashram the monastery was to be very
particular and conscious about my diet
and that diet referred to more than what
I ate more than the food I consumed more
more than the preps I tasted more than
the intake of the nutrients that were
required to mitigate my hunger and keep
my body nourished and fit a healthy diet
also meant being particular about all
those things that I was consuming and
feeding my mind my intellect my inner
self my soul it meant all those sights
sounds smells that I was feeding my
inner system isn't it true that all of
us who want to stay fit and healthy are
very cautious and conscientious about
the quantity and the quality of the food
we eat some of us may eat the right
quality of food but in the wrong
quantity eat too less you may end up
becoming weak eat too much and you may
end up becoming obese and then some of
us may eat the right quantity of food
but of the wrong quality and that could
lead to health issues too good health is
a consequence of a balanced diet the
right quality and the right quantity of
food if we want to be mentally well
emotionally stable intellectually fit
and spiritually inspired we need to have
a balanced diet for these inner aspects
of our life as well I think uh when we
talk about stress dealing with stress
here are the three things I usually
recommend to deal with there are three
s's the first s being strike a balance
in life you know all of us we will have
two components to our life the first
component is the have todos about 95% of
the people in the world today for them
their work is a have to do they don't
love it they don't like it they don't
enjoy it they're just doing it why
because it gives them a paycheck and I
know that a paycheck is important
because it pays the bills you have a
family you have children and the
paycheck is indeed important mortgages
loans emis to pay that's a have too and
have Tod do cause a lot of stress here's
my recommendation you know for sure
whether it's your mom dad sibling wife
husband boyfriend girlfriend child you
know that no human being is perfect
there's going to be a dark side a side
that we don't like in them which is the
have to do the handled part of it but
how do we continue that relationship we
continue that relationship based on our
focus on the bright side of their
personality treat your work as a
relationship start looking at something
bright in your work something good that
you may like something that you can
develop in your work a liking for in a
way that the have to become handleable
and the second component of your work is
your love to do or your like to do the
second thing I talk about in dealing
with stress first is Striker balance
second is seek support you need to seek
emotional support from people around you
there's going to be issues there's going
to be pressures there's going to be
problems there's going to be deadlines
there's going to be challenges everybody
has them which is why when you seek
support emotional support from people
it's not that they have a solution to
the problem they only ensure one thing
that they won't allow you to face that
problem alone just to have someone by
your side makes your stress a little
easier just to be able to confide and
open up to someone what you're going
through makes you feel so light already
and the third thing I talk about of
course is a spiritual connection again
with that spiritual connection we get
the fortitude to be able to face stress
so three s's strike a balance seek
emotional support and spiritually make a
deep connect that's how we can handle
stress we feel guys it's okay to feel we
human beings we will feel and when you
feel the better I can describe to a
doctor how I feel
feel the better the doctor can diagnose
the situation to give me treatment right
if I go and say doctor I have
headache but why anything else doctor I
have headache do you feel nausea doctor
I have headache do you have fever doctor
I have headache do you feel bche no
after I have headache one lady went to a
doctor and the doctor said how's your
headache Madam she said he's out of
town you know when you go to a doctor
it's very important to describe your
symptoms right so when you feel
angry don't just say I'm angry yeah try
to decode what shade of anger are you am
I annoyed am I upset am I irritated am I
frustrated am I anxious because if you
don't know the the finer nuances you
don't know what to address so that's the
feel part after the feel part comes the
deal part and what's the deal part the
deal part is only when I know what is
that
shade then can I address it right only
when the doctor knows with the headache
there's a fever there's nausea and
there's chills maybe it's denu or
malaria right only when I know what
exact feeling I'm going through can I
then look for a possible solution to it
emotional resilience yeah and then when
I deal with it the next part obviously
is healing dealing with us is now and
here healing is a life's journey I would
suggest healing is a process right it is
not an event it's a journey right
dealing can be an event it's here and
the now like wedding is an event
marriage is a journey yeah getting
getting a degree is an event career is a
journey right uh similarly dealing with
a problem is an event but healing is a
journey and trust me it takes time
healing takes time Progressive mindset
is kindness empathy and sensitivity to
the needs of others that's a progressive
mindset you could dress the way you
dress you could speak the language you
speak you may not use any bloody jargon
in your conversation doesn't matter a
bloody damn doesn't matter a bloody Dam
that's called Progressive where you have
sensitivity and empathy to the needs of
others and here we have people who throw
such fancy
jargon not having kindness not having
empathy not having tolerance not having
sensitivity to the other choices that
people have
made if my mother chooses to dress up in
a certain way and speak in a certain way
and chooses to touch the feet of my
father or my her father-in-law is that
regressive doesn't every human being on
planet Earth have the choice to live the
way they
want should any bloody individual or
ideology Define what is Progressive and
regressive
why why here's a lady who I saw who had
such human sensitivity and empathy Pro
progressiveness is a mindset not
jargon it's a mindset and which is why
in a scenario like this the first thing
that we need is kindness empathy
sensitivity to understand each other's
needs we all have that villain in our
life right or we call
them cuz sometimes it's a perception
that they villain sometimes a reality
that they villain we all have that
person in us in our stories we all have
that one person in our
[Music]
stor just to pufy you of all of this
send to that person everybody has that
one person in their lives just one
taster that I want to give you just one
thing is so much can be said on that
topic like I said it's a whole
discussion in
itself but when you forgive
someone that's not necessarily for
them when you forgive someone that is
for
you for your
peace so that you come to peace with
[Music]
things sometimes what they do doesn't
even deserve
forgiveness you know what I say often
forgive or not forgive is a individual
choice if you want to live in peace
however it is imperative that we let go
of what we have held in our mind and we
pent up in our
minds because small or less this phone
may be what 200 g 300 G if I hold this
phone on my palm it's going to hurt me a
little bit for a while if I hold it for
2 hours it's going to hurt my wrist a
lot if I hold it for an entire day it's
going to start numbing my if I hold it
for an entire week without putting it
down it's going to paralyze is my
wrist it's not what you hold and how
long you hold it's not what you hold and
how heavy it is but how long we hold it
so to keep down that
phone is some compassion to my own
wrist not to the
phone so what I hold for somebody is
like that phone it's not so much for
them it's for my own peace it's for my
own my own coming to terms with my own
Joy you
know and and forgiveness doesn't
necessarily mean forgetting
it we've always been told forgive and
forget forgive and forget forgive and
forget no you know what when we are
talking about forgiving and forgetting
forgiving is about stopping that person
that person's actions that person what
that person's doing to influence how we
feel
now
memories are not going to be easily
erased memories of what people have done
to us do you think memories can be
easily
[Music]
erased you know what when I take a am I
okay to take a picture of you all of you
[Music]
guys see I'm going to take a
picture show you good leave
here's a picture
correct if I want to delete this
picture G right it's gone and now if I
go to my trash in this and deleted it's
permanently deleted from the memory
correct but that's because this is a
phone any impression that is made on the
SIM card or on the memory of this phone
in Sanskrit is called a
samsar samsar means an impression that
is made on something it goes through
this lens and leaves an impression on
there but these impressions are very
easy to delete at the Press of a delete
button is got from your
memories guess what ladies and
gentlemen in our life through what we
read hear what happens Happ s to us a
lot of Sams scars happening on this
memory
here and they are not
easy to
delete so I'm not even that's why I said
I'm not even asking you to delete them
you need to be so elevated spiritually
to be able to just go leave it all
behind we are not we are people living
in the real
world so when we say forgive we are
saying don't allow that person Now to
control your
peace let
go but we are also simultaneously saying
that there is going to be that side and
every single time you see that
person imagine an abuser coming in front
of those Med was
abused that
memory to trigger everything back
again right everything back again and
that's precisely why during the course
of my talk I had said forgiveness saying
a sorry doesn't happen we have to make
it happen by shifting our attention
elsewhere a I'll stay away from my
triggers which trigger that memory but
if that memory does come to me and I
feel
angry I feel hurt I feel everything
coming to me I'll be compassionate to my
own self and say it's over
okay it's okay be compassionate to
yourselves compassion is not just meant
for
others so be
self-compassionate if you feel anger you
feel anger if you feel hurt you feel
hurt if you go through what you go
through you go through what you go
through don't stay there because it's
ruining your life a man during his
travels once came up to a mountain where
you found a lady meditating under a tree
quite intrigued by her presence in a
solitary place like this he asked her
what are you doing here alone in such a
secluded place the lady replied that she
had a lot of work to do on that mountain
a little amused the man asked a lot of
work I cannot see anything around you
here what do you have to do up here on
this mountain the lady replied well I to
train two hogs and two Eagles teach two
rabbits discipline one snake motivate a
donkey and tame a lion and if I might
ask you where are they I don't see any
of them up here question the man
actually sir you'll never be able to see
them because they all live inside here
within me said the lady the Hawks stare
at everything that comes to me people
good or bad situations good or bad
things good or bad and have to work hard
to train them to focus on the good side
the Hawks represent the vision behind my
eyes and the two eagles with their claws
can hurt and Destroy I have to train
them not to hurt those Eagles are my
hands that need to do something
constructive for the world and not
create or engage in anything hurtful or
destructive rabbits are very Swift and
they want to go wherever they want to go
I have to teach them to not just run
around but run in the right direction
after all what use is the speed if there
is no Direction the rabbits represent my
feet and I always want them to go in the
right direction in life the donkey is
often lethargic and at times acts very
stubborn I need to motivated to continue
on with its work my mind is exactly like
the donkey it takes up something but
then loses the enthusiasm to continue
and also can be very obstinate at times
a lot of hard work goes into dealing
with this donkey sir to plead with it to
keep going on and on the most difficult
to tame however is the snake although it
is locked in a strong cage with 32 bars
it's always ready to sting bite and
poison anyone nearby I have to
discipline it and that is my tongue I
have one lion too oh how proud how vain
he thinks he's the king I have to tame
him and show him his real position and
that that's my ego so now you see my
dear sir I have lots of work to do up
here on the mountain ladies and
gentlemen all of us have lots of work to
do as well internal work that can
transform our external life so let's
stop gossiping let's stop criticizing
let's stop evaluating and judging others
let's start looking at and working on
our own lives isn't it said yesterday I
was trying to be clever so I wanted to
change the world today I'm trying to be
wise so I know that I need to change
myself spirituality is not about not
feeling low it's about how do you bounce
back to your high how quickly do you
bounce back to your high how happily do
you bounce back to your high how
effectively do you bounce back to your
high that spirit spirituality to say
that you don't feel the low is to say
that you're a dead piece of
wood right and if if a dead piece of
wood doesn't feel low well you don't
even really praise that dead piece of
wood you don't even admire worship or
respect that dead piece of wood because
if it doesn't feel low what do you need
to respect it for you respect people
when they go through a low phase because
with their sheer grit with their sheer
fortitude with their sheer strength and
with their sheer resolve resilience they
have bounced back he that is
spirituality right so I I I absolutely
feel I in fact tell the story of a very
very renowned spiritual Saint in India
uh an entire tradition called The pushti
Mark is followed in India by his name
Shri pradab aara and two men came to him
both seeking spiritual initiation both
speaking seeking Spirit deep spiritual
connection both had lost lost their dear
ones in fact both had lost their sons
and one of them was extremely stoic like
you know no feeling of any you know
grief just stoic his face was like
completely composed peaceful and then
you had the other person who was like
crying
yelling extremely expressive about his
grief and his emotions you could say
that he was going through a low phase in
his life having lost his son so when
both of them approach Shri wachara he
said to the first one that you're not
qualified for spirituality I'm sorry the
one was to one was toic said you're not
qualified for Spiritual initiation you
please go and the second person he
immediately gave shelter and said you
can come I'll initiate you so the first
guy said asked
wachara he said sir I
mean my son is
dead and look at me I'm kind of above
those emo
I'm above those emotions I'm away from
those emotions away from those
feelings so don't you think I qualify
for Spiritual initiation all the
more wachara
said you like a dead stone you no
feelings you have no feelings you have
no
emotions and only a dead stone or a log
of wood is like that he's a human being
as a human being he has his feelings of
low he has grief he has emotions and
because he has feelings now my job is to
redirect and rechannel that energy into
constructive
spirituality spirituality is not about
stoicness spirituality is about how do
you channelize the energy that you're
going through in a constructive purpose
and even sad energy can be used
200% 200% because sad energy is what
actually impels you to do something
better in fact it's in moments of grief
it's in moments of those when you really
hit rock bottom is when you start
looking for meaning and purpose right
Man's Search for meaning Victor Frankle
what is it the whole book is about this
it is in those moments at in those
concentration camps going through so
much that he started looking for Man's
Search for purpose for meaning in fact
we look for meaning we look for purpose
only when we hit rock bottom right don't
they say that when you're very very
happy listen to the music of the song
and when you're very sad you listen to
the
lyrics when you're really elated man
nobody listens to the lyrics shooting a
missile straight
here so I I so much feel that it's it's
these moments it's those low phases of
our life that actually make us there are
going to be things which you can't
change like my headache 29 years and
you're still always smiling you're
always smiling every time we see you
you're smiling and you're giving hope to
people you're being positive try my
bit so the a in the car stands for
accept what you can't
change when you know that there's
nothing you can do about it you have to
accept
it and then when you realize that you
can't even accept it there certain
things you can't even accept the r
stands for you have to rise above
it or remove yourself from a lady friend
of mine 25 she got married and in 6
months she found out her husband's
gay look I have no problem with
somebody's sexual orientation is their
choice right but what does this lady do
he's stuck in a relationship with her
husband's
gay she can't change she can't accept
the only solution was our which was
remove herself from
that toxic
relationship but when you have a pain
like this you can't change you can't
accept you can't
remove that is when I feel Rising above
is important spirituality mindfulness
meditation conscious breathing being in
your own
space to be able to come to terms with
it and just because someone has
struggles doesn't mean sorry just
because somebody's smiling doesn't mean
they don't have struggles it just means
they' chosen to focus on the brighter
side and deal with the ne negative side
of their life not not to deal with it
but chosen to focus on the brighter side
I travel the world and Council corporate
professionals and the one thing I hear
all the time is we being paid very well
but we don't feel fulfilled in what we
do right is a job just meant to pay or
is a job also meant to fulfill you're
going to spend the majority of your time
at
work in the morning a couple of hours at
home in the evening a couple of hours at
home and the rest of the day at work if
the majority of your time is going to be
going at work should you just be doing
that's giving you something that's going
to give pay you well or also something
that's going to fulfill you absolutely
so when I was working a job at hiet
peard the one question I asked myself is
do I see myself doing this for the rest
of my life right I'm great at it
absolutely phenomenal at it I'm like
absolutely smashing it but do I see
myself doing this for the rest of my
life and the answer was a loud clear no
I cannot because this doesn't fulfill me
so the question was what fulfills me I
didn't want to work with machines and
systems I preferred working with people
right so obviously the choices were
still study Psychiatry study psychology
study behavioral economics
organizational all to do with people
yeah and then I also found I had a
spiritual calling MH so I decided could
I find answers to The Human
Condition in spirituality right which is
when that that twist came to my life
that I said okay let me explore answers
to life in spirituality where I combine
my passion and my calling together if I
might ask all of you what is the weight
of this phone like approximately
200 g 250 g
maybe imagine if I were to hold this
phone on my palm just about 250
g but if I were to hold it for the next
20 minutes of my answering
questions probably start hurting my
wrist a little bit if I were to hold it
for the rest of the evening without
putting it
down I'm going to really start hurting
my wrist a
lot and if I were to hold this phone on
my palm for the rest of the week without
putting it down my wrist will probably
start getting a little
number numb isn't it now it's not so
much about the weight of the phone it's
for how long am I carrying it on my palm
right our past memories our stresses
what's happened to us is like something
that we are lugging in our mind
constantly
it could be a small thing it could be a
big thing but when we are lugging
something in our mind constantly it's
like exactly like holding this phone on
my palm non-stop it's going to start
affecting my
wrist if I'm going to think about my
this relative of mine friend this book
the stories in my book energize your
mind the second book where I talk about
how this relative of mine came up on my
father's funeral day I was my father's
body still lying there and this
gentleman says that I was the cause of
my father's death in front of
everybody now who has gotten an insult
like
that where you called the cause of your
father's death in a public forum and the
father my father's body is not even
crated
yet now every single time I see this
guy you know how every it becomes like a
stimulus a trigger to bring back those
past memories an entire chapter in the
book is about dealing with these
memories right PTSD right post-traumatic
stress disorder just so much in there
just like this all the
time this is exactly what I'm doing to
my mind exactly what I did to my palm my
memories my anxieties my past
Impressions is doing this now
imagine you can't really take it off
will you be able to take the 2611
experience off your mind completely
never will I be able to take out that
statement that this gentleman made about
my father's death saying I was the cause
of my my father's dead
never and each one of us has our own
stories and memories and Impressions
that we have in our mind we're not going
to be able to take it out of our minds
ever somebody hurt you deeply and there
was a heartbreak somebody had in a
relationship how is a person going to
take it off from their
mind you cannot take it off completely
ladies and gentlemen but I know one
thing I can at least occasionally keep
it down if I
can that'll make my wrist feel a little
better because it's going to come back
up again here I've consciously chosen to
put the phone down it's not jumping back
on my palm but in my mind I might
consciously try to purge my thoughts up
but going to come back in my mind
again but even if for those 20 minutes
an hour a day if I can keep it away my
mind is feeling relaxed and better which
is precisely
why a mental
detox is extremely essential and
imperative
to be able to keep a stable frame of
mind and what how does one detox one's
mind there's so many ways to do it
meditation of course is one way to do it
but one very very very powerful way to
do it is journaling
journaling journaling is an extremely
powerful way of pouring out everything
that you have in your
mind on paper how do you find your
purpose in life quick one pointer on it
somebody asked
Michelangelo they said sir you make such
beautiful
sculptures I mean what's the secret
behind making such
Exquisite you know top of the end
sculptures Michelangelo gave an answer
which was like spoton absolutely
incredibly inspiring he said I really
don't make those sculptures those
sculptures exist within the chunk of the
marble what I do is I chisel off the
excess marble from the top and what is
existing will eventually emerge out
right I feel our purpose is like that
sculpture so finding your purpose is not
an overnight thing sir it's a life's
journey some people hit onto it really
quick some people and most people I
would say take long one thing I can
definitely say our purpose is not just
to come to this world earn money pay
bills pay taxes pay mortgages we're not
born to just pay taxes builds mortgages
that's not what we Bor for there's
something more that we definitely have
and it'll come in time if we seek it if
we declutter if we take all those layers
that are off slowly and steadily we take
them off we will slowly reach there all
the distractions we see on our
path are only because our eyes are not
fixed on our purpose and our goal right
so if anything that I feel is
inconvenient is because my eyes are way
wavering away from what I've come here
for if I'm here for a purpose and my
mission my eyes my in concentration my
focus is completely on what I'm meant to
get then I'm going to be able to handle
those inconveniences is there any any
time in our life that we won't have
inconveniences there will always be some
problems there will always be some
inconvenience all how many of you have
problems in your life everyone in how
many of you want a solution for problems
in your life
take up your smartphones guys go to your
wallpaper settings change your home
screen and your lock screen uh wallpaper
to the picture of your spouse if you're
married and to the picture of your
boyfriend or girlfriend if you're not
married if you're in a relationship and
whenever you have a big challenge like
my food my sharing space just pick up
your phone and look at it like
this and say to yourself if I can handle
this I can handle any damn thing in my
life
well done thank you just joking guys
just joking so the point is challenges
problems distractions will go to the
side when attention is on what we are
meant to achieve challenges distractions
will seem very prominent when our eyes
are off our goal that's what I kept
aligning myself with and inconveniences
just melted away withered away and
everything became such a part of life
such a joyous life today even the boa
and the Alo the one thing that I've
learned over the years is that we are
all so different our lives are so
different our situations are so
different our backgrounds are so
different our upbringing is so different
the Journey of our life up until now for
each one of us is so different compared
to somebody else and therefore it's so
important that we don't judge our own
life or the lives of other others by
comparing them with someone else's life
here's an example if Mr a can Sprint a
distance of 10 km in 1 hour whereas Mr B
covers the same distance in 1 and 1/2
hour which one of the two would you call
faster and
healthier the answer obviously would be
Mr a now what if I tell you that Mr a
had a prepared track to run on when Mr B
dided by walking on a Sandy path I think
our answer will now change and we
probably think that Mr B is fitter and
let's say we come to know that actually
Mr a is 75 years old while B is only 20
here we go our answer changes again and
we now think that the 75-year-old Mr a
is healthier guess what Mr a weighs 60
kg whereas Mr B 125 kg which makes it
really hard for him to run who do you
think did well oh my goodness now we
correct ourselves again as we favor Mr B
the more we get to know about the
strengths and limitations of Mr A and B
respectively our opinions and judgments
about who is better keep changing and
isn't life like that as well guys we
form opinions about others so quickly so
hastily so impulsively so superficially
without knowing much about them or their
situations we end up judging people
labeling people and miss out on
connecting to and encouraging the
immense potential that they may have
life is not the same for all some may
not be as talented as others but may get
better opportunities and thus scale up
very fast whereas others despite being
super talented keep struggling just to
make the ends
meet
some may have more resources whereas
others can't find any source to fall
back on each one has different problems
and so no one solution can work for all
just like one size of clothing doesn't
fit all so do not judge others Journey
without knowing more do not judge your
own life by looking at someone else's or
comparing your situation with someone
someone else's you are you and they are
they your life is your life and theirs
is theirs do take inspiration from their
journey in a way that you can enrich
yours and always remember life is the
most difficult exam many people fail
because they try to copy others not
realizing that everyone has a
different question paper how many of you
breathe
I am sorry for asking that question how
many of you been breathing for the last
couple of minutes as I started this
talk I'm sure all of you have how many
of you are conscious of your
breathing mindful of your breathing I
don't think so any of us how many of you
use an Apple watch any of you here and
do you know that on an Apple Watch
there's a facility which gives you
giving you reminders after every 1 hour
time to
breathe
yeah if you use an Apple Watch you know
that it gives you a reminder after every
1 hour time to breathe and focus and
being mindful of your breathing ladies
and
gentlemen none of us in the last one odd
hour of shall I say through the day have
been conscious of our breathing now
imagine when you start breathing and you
just keep breathing in and then and then
and then and then can you
live no and imagine if you start
breathing out and you breathe out and
you breathe out and you breathe out and
you breathe out and you breathe out can
you
live now can you imagine how life is
fashioned in such an incredible
sophisticated refined
Rhythm the rhythm of
breathing when we talk about life we
talk about the rhythm of
breathing where so unconsciously this
taking in and this giving out this
taking in and this giving out if we just
keep taking in we choke up and if we
just keep giving out we choke up what an
incredible balance life has to teach us
what an incredible Rhythm simply our
breathing has to teach us that life
can't just be a life of takers where we
just keep taking taking just taking or
taking nor can life be
just giving giving giving giving
giving the rhythm of breathing gives us
an incredible
[Music]
message take in to give
out
have to
share
grab to care that incredible balance
that
incredible equation is what makes life
amazing I've done three talks in three
cities in B in India
early late morning like about 9ish I've
spoken in Bangalore in India after that
Z come to the airport go to Chennai for
another one finish that and come back to
Mumbai and straight from the airport go
to another I've done three talk in three
cities in a day what do you if I snap
well you're technically right I did but
you're practically wrong ladies and
gentlemen I don't snap like that you can
interact with me all the time I don't
snap like that but I'm a human body and
a human machine in your relationships
ladies and gentlemen I make a humble
appeal to all of you and beg of you life
is
short it's very
short don't mess up with people the
closest people to
you give time to
them and understand
them they may be you they may have said
something here and there and you may be
technically right okay look at at the
Hidden Mango yes your husband or your
wife may not love you and that's
technically
right but there may be a Hidden Mango
why find that out before you brand them
your son of daughter may not listen to
you and you may be completely
technically right that they don't obey
you but find out the Hidden Mango why
are they doing what they are doing they
are doing that is clear everybody knows
it it doesn't need two pin worth of
Common Sense is it a rocket science to
understand that is it a rocket sign to
understand he's not behaving right any
damned fool can understand
it it needs intelligence and maturity to
go behind the technical rightness and
look for the Practical rightness it
looks it needs maturity and wisdom to
start seeing behind the scene to say why
is this person not loving me why is this
person behaving like that why is this
person not treating me right and if you
do that believe me hand on my heart your
love for whoever you
love will go so deep and your
relationship with whoever you relate to
will be so profound because it's based
on maturity not judgmentalism I feel
over a period of time to me there are
four things that really
distinguish a good leader from others
and the first
thing is the
Curiosity to always know and learn
the humility and the vulnerability to
say that I don't
know a lot of times the blind spot of
having achieved a certain amount of
knowledge is to think that I've cracked
it and I Know
It Innovation creativity growth comes
from
Curiosity and the vulnerability and
humility to say that well this is what I
don't know growth comes from not this
line that I know growth comes from I
don't know which means I have the
Curiosity to learn if you understood
life right you would know that when you
grow up you want to be happy yeah and I
feel when you happy doing what you do is
when you make the most impact correct if
I'm a motivational speaker and not happy
being a motivational speaker what am I
giving to the world a product not not my
joy not what I truly feel or not the
real not the authentic self so if I'm
authentic it makes a tremendous impact
in what I do so of course it comes with
time I can't can't say that when I was
growing up I felt that I'm going to make
a difference I'm going to be my genuine
self and authentic self I took to the
beaten path of being an engineer but
then with time they realized that this
is not me I can't fit in I can't just
conform I can't just comply with
whatever just existing I need to find my
voice and not Dr myself in the noise
that's going on all around us in society
astrology Jo
shastra
palster parrot cards tarot
cards everyone's wanting to
know the
secret that life holds for
future how many of you would like to
take a journey into the
future
thank you how many of you would be
interested to know how long you would
live there are some courageous
Souls how many of you would like to know
who your life partner would
be oh my God astrology is such a big
thing I was is coming from uh some
country and it was a free flight 75 of
us and one man was totally drunk I was
sitting there he comes up to me and say
Pandit
G pit
G I
said he stuck his palm out I said
liveris he
said I said it doesn't require astrology
to see the way you're drunk that you'll
get liosis you know one guy came up to
an
astrologer and said
problem looked at his
said
this guy
said so he
said
[Applause]
what will sheny do to you you know you
get lost if you don't have anything what
will shy anyways do to
you I'm sure all of us are looking for
answers of what would happen with us
isn't it one who's born will be dead one
who's dead will be born we have no
control I didn't have any control over
how I was born and where I was born I
didn't have any control over what my
looks were what family I was born in
what country I was born in what what
soci economic class I was born in I had
no control over
it and I must say that we truly have no
control over when life ends and how we
die just Cardinal Facts of
Life but there's something that we have
control
over which can make life
beautiful therefore I generally say life
is a journey between two
alphabets B
and D where b stands for birth and d
stands for death what is in control is
between the alphabets B and D is an
alphabet called
C between B and D is a c and that c is
choice we can all learn to choose as we
live our lives we can all learn to
choose not to prove but to
improve we can all learn to choose not
to react but to respond we can all learn
to choose how not to get affected by
what's happening in our lives all around
us and it does our life is a matter of
choices live
well it won't easily go wrong you can't
change your situations you can change
your response ladies and gentlemen this
is the noise
around the noise around is get a job
have a
startup make
money get married have children
pretty much what life is for everybody
out there in the world right that's the
noise and a lot of times I feel in that
noise somewhere we forget to listen to
our own voice some people in order to
follow their dreams they St away from
the people whom they
love and some people in order to be with
the people whom they love they forget
their dreams and their in a voice so as
I was studying preparing for my exams
looking at the grades looking at what
could be the career options for the
future there was one thing that was
definitely
happening that one that that aspect of
me saying that well I don't want to
necessarily given to the noise that was
brewing that was brewing that was that
was changing with it I don't necessarily
want to belong to that noise and listen
to that noise yeah uh and that's
probably why then this decision
came that I don't want to necessarily
conform I don't want to be just a part
of the noise and I'm not against what
people say getting married is perfectly
fine having children is perfectly fine
building a nice house is perfectly fine
having a fantastic well-paying job with
a th thick fat paycheck is perfectly
fine if that's not me if that's not my
voice I felt hey I'm not going to do
this right wow I'm not going to do this
was revolutionary it was Radical yeah it
was taking The Road Less Traveled not
traveled shall I not even less traveled
shall I say not traveled
practically uh taking a big time risk
yeah uh but yes I followed my heart I
followed that voice how uh important
self-control is in our life so basically
when I see you there's a lot of food
besides you and you are only eating D
rice when we edit videos in our Hiles
office and we see a lot of good food and
we also feel like crave for eating food
so do you feel like you know craving for
things uh number one to be honest God
has been kind in the last couple of
years I've practically gone everywhere
seen everything eaten every possible
thing that could have you know been
available uh strangely as a monk it's
very strange that a monk gets to do all
of this stuff but I've gotten to do all
of that so there's a point in time when
you kind of say I've seen it all done it
all kind of stuff so then you naturally
come to stage of okay bus but also
through my having said that 26 years
I've been taught a life of control in my
monk Life as a monk uh for the first
couple of years I was not couple of
years probably about more than a decade
I could only eat what was cooked in the
community kitchen if I like it I don't
like it doesn't matter whatever meal is
cooked I would eat that right now do I
have cravings yes I do I'm a human being
I'm a human being right I have my cheat
days of course I I work out I work out
heavy but I have my cheat days too last
four five days I've been too much
cheating
but but I have my cheat days too not
that I don't not at all I'll tell you
how it is if we are at the race course
right just right behind the race course
when you ride a
horse if you let the Rin of the horse a
little too
loose the horse goes Haywire runs Helter
Skelter all over the place if you
tighten the rings of the horse a little
too tight you'll see the horse Mak
screechy sound and comes up on its two
two
legs now too tight problem too loose
problem that's how the mind and the
senses are the reality is technology has
added value the reality is with the
brightest minds and with the brightest
opportunities and the brightest avenues
that have opened up technolog is
escalating to the next
level the reality of the matter is also
this that when technology comes up
there as aayush rightly said it kind of
becomes a
threat to human existence to human
potential to the development of human
potential I was in Singapore one year
for an event called masters of the
century one of the keynote speakers and
I came up on stage I I did my bit I love
love cracking jokes cracking people up
there's about 2,000 people in the
audience not a single Indian face I mean
you don't have a single Indian face
that's when you test your grounds
because when there's Indians they can
immediately connect I an Indian you can
really frequencies match but there I was
looking at people enjoyed it they gave
me a standing ovation and I went
backstage and when I went
backstage everybody started shouting
Sophia Sophia Sophia Sophia
and I said these guys got it
wrong like and if you if you want an
encore they should have shouted go goal
G gopal I said this guys have gotten it
wrong once I did an event and people did
shout because they wanted me to be up on
stage again go go Sophia sopia I turned
to my secretary I said who the heck is
the
sopia so this one guy come up comes up
to me and says would you like to meet
Sophia
sir I S oh oh I don't mind actually
considering the kind of enthusiasm from
the audience looks like sopia must be as
someone and I thought in my mind it was
probably Sophia Vergara from Modern
Family so they said we'll take you to
see her so I I was walking towards the
The Green Room where Sophia was in my
mind thinking of any possible reference
from Modern Family so that when I meet
Sophia Vergara I say ma'am I saw this
and it was a real life night good to
connect on something that is common as I
came to the Green Room there was two
huge bouncers their muscles were
Rippling out of their coats like real
loud there they were standing there I
said this guy said I I'd like to see
Sophia said sorry Sophia is getting
plugged
in I said Sophia is getting plugged in
seemed like a new slang seemed like a
new slang Singaporean slang was plugged
in or zoned in so I thought plug PL in
would mean like you know speakers like
to get plugged into the Ambiance the
atmosphere just be in their space and I
was thinking like this maybe she's doing
makeup maybe she's doing div some makeup
some using some device to plug in and
soon after the doors open and there were
two guys who were carrying the first
ever humanoid that was made on planet
Earth who was called Sophia and when
they say she's getting plugged in means
literally getting plugged in and getting
charged Sophia came up on stage I I
should St in the audience to listen to
what Sophia said and they asked her a
very
touchy sensitive question the funny part
is the answer was programmed in
Sophia they asked her do you think
artificial
intelligence and the technology that has
come up today will replace human beings
the question that aush has asked me I
cannot
forget what Sophie had answered in fact
my second book energize your mind begins
with the story right the story of
sopia and I can't forget what Sophia
said Sophia
said it needs a human being to create a
Sophia and therefore there's no question
ever that a Sophia can replace a human
being because without a human being a
Sophia cannot function you need an
answer to be programmed into a machine
and even with the growth of some of
these artificial engines with no names
the day before yesterday I typed into
one of them and you know what I mean no
names you know what I mean I typed in to
figure out the details of one of my
friends who's a massive
businessman his son who's now leading
the business to check details guess what
guys he's just about 34 years
old this particular AI engine said that
he was dead in
1944 was dead in
1944 it requires a sensient human being
true to run technology to create
technology and that's why Sophia I
remember
said I'm not here to compete with human
beings I'm here to
complement human beings and what human
beings do and what human beings do to
complement what human beings do it's our
human
responsibility to while we use all
technology to while we upgrade to the
best that is
available to not do away with the human
potential that is behind it who this
teacher in London this in London she
came to the class and she asked all the
kids a question I want to give you all
an
assignment I want all of you to write on
your
notebooks answers to this
question what do you want to be
when you grow
up and the obvious answers Engineers
doctors actors and nowadays social media
influencers
YouTubers you know like insta Stars
nowadays the things have changed
engineer
[Music]
engine nowadays youngster
engineer
YouTuber and nowadays narratives have
changed people say
monk can you believe that change of
narrative because this is like monk
swag I'm like a monk with a
swag so nowadays youngsters
say change of
narrative so everybody wrote their
answers one boy was sitting in the class
he hadn't written it it was taking a
little longer but the teacher came to
the boy and said you not written your
answer yet so just
finishing she just said what do you want
to be when you grow
up the boy said I want to be
happy the teacher looked at him Gob
smacked like Gob
smacked she said look son I don't think
you understood the
assignment the boy turned to the teacher
and said look ma'am I don't think you
understood
life because if you would have
understood life you would know
well that what you want to
be when you grow
up is happy and the legendary boy who
gave this legendary answer was none but
John Lennon from the Beatles right he
was the one who gave this
answer when you turn 22 what do you want
to
be when you turn 42 what do you want to
be when you want to turn 62 what do you
want to be when you turn a billionaire
what do you want to be when you reach
the peak of your career what do you want
to be a very
simple a very simple answer we all want
to
be happy a lady named Maria lived with
her mother in a small apartment she was
not too young nor too old not too short
nor Too Tall either not particularly
beautiful nor was she ugly Maria was
just an average woman she worked as a
secretary at a large company in her life
was pretty boring and
mundane no one at work ever paid any
attention to her and those who did
considered her to be as boring as her
life was one morning on her way to work
Maria saw a new hat shop that had opened
just down street out of curiosity she
walked in in the shop was a lady with
her daughter would come to pick a hat
for her girl and a couple of other
customers who were trying different
hats Maria also tried a few hats until
she found one she truly liked she put it
on and it looked really nice the first
one to notice was the little girl who
exclaimed mommy look how pretty that
woman looks with the hat on the mother
said ma'am I must say this hat looks
awesome on you another man in the shop
also came up to Maria and said ma'am you
look lovely with that hat on Maria went
to the mirror she looked at herself and
for the first time in years she she
liked her own look smiling she went to
the counter and bought the Hat as she
walked outside a new world revealed
itself to her like never before she
never before noticed the colors of the
flowers around her or smelt the scent of
the fresh air even the sounds of the
cars and people on the road sounded like
a harmonious Mel
City she walked as if she was Drifting
On A Cloud with a song being played in
her heart when she passed by the same
coffee shop she walked by every morning
a young handsome man called out to her
hey you're looking gorgeous can I buy a
cup of coffee for you she blushed kept
walking floating on the cloud of her
Newfound Joy when she got to theice
office building the doorman opened the
door and wished her good morning never
before had he even noticed her the
people in the elevator asked her the
floor she needed and pressed the button
for Maria her colleagues at the office
as if seeing her for the very first time
praised her on how lovely she looked
that day the manager asked her out to
lunch
to talk about how she felt at work when
this extraordinary work day was over she
decided to take a cab back home instead
of the bus as soon as she put her hand
up two taxis stopped she took the first
one and sat in the back seat thinking
about the magical day she had had and
how her life felt so different and
changed thanks to the new hat when she
got home her mom opened the door the
sight of Maria took her breath
away Maria she said surprised you're
looking fabulous today your eyes are all
lit up like when you were a little girl
yes Mom said Maria it's all thanks to my
new hat I had the most marvelous day in
years new hat asked the confused mother
which hat are you talking about Maria
panicked she touched her head only to
realize that the hat that had changed
her life was not there she tried
remembering where she may have left it
in the cab no at lunch I don't think so
at the office not at all she thought of
the store where she had bought it how
she had noticed it for the first time
how she had put it on her head how she
had gone to pay for it at the
Cashers oh my goodness she remembered
how she had put it on the counter to get
her purse out to pay and how she had
forgotten it right there on the counter
and then she had walked out right there
to the street
hatless yet
glowing ladies and gentlemen it wasn't
the external hat that made Maria's day
great it was the quality of her internal
dialogue that transformed how she felt
our internal dialogue can enslave us
into a horrible routine life or can
liberate us making our life full of
Gusto energy passion and joy change your
hat inside today and look at the magic
of how the outside hat simply adds on to
your already
existing
gorgeous in a beauty like sometimes you
find child
prodigies you know they're like Masters
in singing or dancing or writing or
whatever they do like it you see
2-year-old kids when their hands work go
on a piano he Spellbound now don't tell
me that he could learn that and master
it at that
age don't tell me a 2-year-old can't
master the
alphabet don't tell me that he mastered
it by learning it in fact nobody taught
it to him he got it he got it now when
you say he got it don't call it genetic
how does how do genes give you a music
skill you know how so I know kids young
little kids who are like prodigies in
what they do at 1 and a half at
two it's absolutely phenomenal and then
now where is where is faith and belief
here it's rational logic that this guy
has it it not come from learning it's
not come from Reading nobody impart it
to him must come from somewhere How can
there be an effect Without a Cause
absolutely and I can't see an immediate
cause right now so there has to be a
remote cause before this right you know
what I mean whether I call it karma
whether I call it whatever but I I can't
accept an effect without a cause it's a
against my rational thinking you know so
now if this gentleman this little boy or
little little girl he or she has this
incredible
Talent we call it the common parlons is
he or she's god- gifted absolutely
absolutely God Gifted Man look at sky
yeah not learned look at how they're
doing it so that is that to me is call
it luck call it Destiny call it karma
Call It Whatever
I didn't get I didn't grab it I got it
Matthew
mccon when he got the
Oscar he said something phenomenal I
loved
it uh in fact it's written in the book
as well he first of course thank God
thanked his wife thanked his father
thanked his mom and he said I want to
thank
God I want to thank God
because opportunities are not given by
the human hand I didn't seek a lot and
it came to
me how do I explain it there's a million
other people who are seeking they don't
get it that's right and I don't seek and
I get it what am I going to explain it
by you know abely you know what I mean
now what that little one does with that
Talent or what that what this gentleman
does or this lady does with the
opportunity that has
come is my free will correct or my my
choice whether to drive right or to
drive left or to not drive right correct
but the
car for a lot of people was given yes
correct now uh that Free Will part is
where I often like to quote I say uh I
don't know who said it but it's a
beautiful quote says when hard work
beats Talent when talent doesn't work
hard
[Music]
absolutely you know yeah so now the
talent came to you when you were two but
if you don't do nothing with it it has
no meaning it has no meaning so you
didn't drive the car yeah you grossly
abused the Fantastic gift the car that
you were given abut correct and then the
others may not get a car like that but
they have their own car yes which they
now need to identify that's called
self-discovery yes to be able to
identify what's the car you've been
given what's what's it that you've been
gifted with and everybody has been
gifted with something there are five
levels of
people on level one the lowest level is
a person who only sees bad in others For
Heaven's Sake that guy just cannot see
any good anyone here like that I don't
think so we're not so bad that we just
can't see any good some people just
can't see any you know it's like when
you like someone even if the guy does
the biggest crime you say
Mar you like him but when you don't like
someone even if he does the good best
thing you don't like him and if you have
that experience if you just don't like
someone even if he has all the good
qualities you just can't like
him there are some people on the lowest
level they only focus on the bad they
can't see the good a level higher are
those who see the good and the bad
but conveniently ignore the good and
focus on the
bad how often it happens when we live
with people there's so many good things
in them but conveniently we neglect the
good things and only focus on the bad my
husband digs the nose
[Music]
okay he digs his nose but he also does
many other good things how come you
forgot all of those and only water how
you only saw that
how come you only saw that you know we
conveniently neglect the good and focus
on the bad the third category of people
are those who see good and
bad equally and they're neutral they're
not concerned good bad they're in their
own
world the fourth category are those who
see the good and
bad they choose to ignore the bad or
deal with the
bad and focus on the good
if you want to like a person you have to
be on level
four if you want to like a person if
you're on level two where you're
ignoring the good and focusing on the
bad how will you like that person and
how will that relationship be
deep when you're on level four where you
choose to ignore the bad or if the need
be deal with the bad and focus on the
good and the fifth level is those who
only see good that's God and spiritually
enlightened individuals who will only
see good in others anybody here who's on
level one only seeing bad can raise your
hand nobody okay thank you anybody is
here on level five only seeing good if
you raise your hand I don't believe you
oh sorry madam I do believe you I'm I
didn't see you raise your hand I was
just joking sorry I'm I I truly believe
you madam I I didn't see you raise your
hand please I just happen to say by
thinking nobody is thank you madam we
really appreciate can we give a loud
Round of Applause for her my God
amazing okay now in your close
relationships in your close
relationships how many of you find
yourself many times stuck at level
two level two where you kind of look at
the bad and forget the good that they
have thank
you in our relationships we need to come
to level
four you know when we're talking about
science and spirituality I I feel that I
never felt there is a divide or a
difference right I feel the purpose is
one right when we look at both having
the same purpose which is to unve the
truth correct science is trying to unve
the truth right and spirituality is
wanting to unwe the truth correct so how
are we different in our purpose correct
the methodology
may be different like in science I may
use uh
uh equipment I may use instruments I may
use telescopes I measurements I may use
so many different things to be able to
figure out what that truth is correct
and I will yes I will phenomenally will
correct so from science and from all
what I
see I have facts not not complete facts
yet which is why it's always evolving we
call it a relative science it's not an
absolute science M's periodic table
right the values were changing right we
found out the truth later we assigned a
certain value said sorry sir this is not
what it is this is the actual value so
it's changing so could I say that this
is it may not be if I get an instrument
which is better than what I have today
I'll probably explore another layer of
that same facet right now that's where I
get the facts great I need those facts
when we talk about spirituality it is
giving the purpose of those
facts so we should be working in tandem
spirituality and S science Were Meant to
work in tandem one looking at unveiling
the truth by giving us factual
data and one saying giving the
philosophical side saying what is the
purpose of this data correct what is the
purpose of this existence and both are
two important Dimensions to the same
truth absolutely you know so I I feel
that's an artificial divide it's an
artificial divide and and it's rigidity
on both parts both sides that we can't
come together to sit and say hey
look like like I I'll give you an
example should a doctor should a doctor
repair a
car that's not a skill set yeah should a
car mechanic try try do an open heart
surgery no so if I this is my area of
expertise let me do that much and not
delve into something further let
somebody else with this other area of
expertise come together and let's pull
it all together to unve the truth
together adding our own Dimension to
it I really want you to help us with one
life advice that we all should follow in
2023 along with the celebration I think
we should also have some deliberation
okay and the deliberation should be on
what went right in the last year
whatever went right can we bring it to
this year and also build upon it
deliberation on what went wrong in the
last year can we even correct it a
little bit and improvise it Rectify it a
little bit because not let's not just
make parties events social functions as
celebrations let's make life as a
celebration yeah and if we want to make
life a celebration in 2023 I think we
should look at what went
right bring it back into 2023 what went
wrong Rectify a little bit of that in
2023 and we should always remember that
in the book of our life yeah uh many
chapters of our book are written already
and the last chapter of whatever your
ages today yeah 31st of December this
year that that chapter will be closed as
well right you can't do anything
anything about it but beginning first of
January the new chapter that year is
completely blank don't feel too much
remorse don't feel too much guilt don't
live in that trap that I'm I didn't do
it I couldn't do it I'm a failure let's
begin aesh with Zeal with enthusiasm
with tremendous Hope and Faith and
confidence that I can do it I will do it
I will take support and help whenever
need it but I'll get where I want to be
ladies and gentlemen in the modern era
we have mastered the art of being
successful I'm not sure if we have
mastered the art of feeling successful
and there's a big difference between
being successful and feeling successful
being successful is quantum
numbers and feeling successful is
quality as you get all the numbers that
you dream for as you get all the numbers
that you work hard for that you get all
the numbers that you're passionate
about are you also looking at quality
with the
quantity so yes climbing up is about the
quantity but carrying the key along is
about the quality of your lives and I
think it's such a crucial aspect even if
you're looking at enhancing your
performance only if you lead a quality
life can you enhance
effectively otherwise a stressed out guy
is more in his stress and is
God Optimum performance what the hell
when the mind is not in place what are
we talking about Optimum performance cut
Corners you know cut Corners being
successful is about what others think of
you feeling successful is what you think
about your own life everybody thinks
these are F guys you know everybody
thinks these guys are driving big sedens
everybody thinks oh gosh these guys are
making money
man everybody thinks you are doing
exceedingly
well what are you thinking about
yourself what are you thinking about
your life who cares a heck what others
think about our lives what do we think
about our lives is the question that we
all need to ask ourselves so I'm not
against being successful for sure I'm
saying while we are trying to be
successful we need to live our life in a
way that we can also feel successful so
today this evening afternoon rather I
would give to you two
keys
one how to feel successful in your
work and second how to be successful in
your work so I'm going to give you the
key when you walk up but I'm also going
to talk to you about how to reach 290
from from
29 both ways both are important go up
and carry the key along but first I'll
talk about the key because that's my
home
ground you know that's my home ground
you can't catch me on the wrong foot
there
hopefully okay how many of you were good
at
mats okay great how many of you are
terrible at
mats how many of you didn't care any
less good or bad pass exam I just get it
done sometimes they say math stands for
mentally affected teachers harassing
students of the full form of Mach you
know this this is kind harassing us with
this mathematic I I I'm an electrical
engineer so mathematics came really easy
to me it was a part of my life I you
know it's like in every cell of your
body there's BS for engineers one
teacher came to a classroom once and
said to the kids if uh a ship is sinking
a frog is croaking and potatoes are 20
rupees a kilo guess what my age
[Music]
is the student said ma'am can you come
back with the question
please the teacher said well a ship is
sinking a frog is croaking and potatoes
are 20 rupees for a kilo guess what my
age is one student raised his hand and
said 32 Madam 32 she said you spot on
man ma but how did you get that right
the guy said look my sister is 16 years
old and is half
mad you wouldn't have
a who would ask such an
unconnected question now since I'm an
engineer by profession and since you
guys are in the financial Market dealing
with numbers I'm going to talk about
life and
numbers I think life is an
equation and I'm going to talk about a
professional
life you guys sitting right here your
professional life is two components to
it two parts of the equation of your
professional life number one the have to
do you have to do your
work have to what a horrible word that
is I have to go to
work I have to do it I have to meet with
this deadline how how many of you have
to meet up with deadlines what a word
isn't it
deadline by the time you cross the line
you know what
happens your moral is
dead have to work any of you go through
work stress I'll tell you what guys
under performance pressure even roosters
have to lay eggs bloody eggs and what do
I mean by laying eggs under performance
pressure doing something that I don't
love doing something that I'm not cut
for doing something that I'm absolutely
not passionate about I traveled the
world speaking to Big corporate
houses and it's not an exaggerated
number over
80% of the professionals who are working
out there are getting a thick fat
paycheck because they're so absolutely
phenomenally great at what they do but
they're not fulfilled with what they do
they're not satisfied with what they do
I was I was sharing with ABA and
equation that if you're working for
about 8 hours a day average and if you
have a 5 days work week you spend 40
hours a week at your
workplace if you have 2 weeks a holiday
in a
year which you spend about which is 50
weeks 50 weeks you working for you spend
about 2,000 hours at your workplace and
if you're working for an average of
about 45 years you spend a bloody 90,000
hours at your workplace and that's a
daunting
number 90,000 hours account to about 10
years of your life and I have a simple
question am I going to be spending
990,000 hours in misery doing something
that I'm paid for but I'm not fullfilled
with I I I took that leap I jumped out
of the corporate world I left
Packard to chase something that I love
to do but I definitely do not Advocate
that my principle that I talk to people
about
is get paid for what you're great
at and also side by side add to your
life what you love your passion even if
it is by the side because passion
doesn't pay your bills immediately
passion doesn't pay your mortgages and
financial liabilities imedi so it's easy
to say that I need to be satisfied with
what I do but there we live in the real
world so love what you do and do what
you love do you get the confidence then
that the world tomorrow will be a better
place than it is today let me tell you
an interesting story there was a ship
sailing on the
ocean and one of the sailors on the ship
came back to the captain and said
Captain it's dark in the night can't see
anything Captain we are in for a head-on
collision
there's a ship right in front of us the
captain said signal to them you change
course
20° back came a reply we not going to
change course 20° you change course
20° the captain said to the Sailor send
a message we are a battles send a
message I am the captain of the ship
back came a reply tell the captain I an
ordinary seaman
the captain was
infuriated I the captain telling him in
ordinary of Sean telling me change
course 20° the captain said send a
message signal them we are a
battleship back came the reply tell the
captain we are the lighthouse
right
now you know something a lighthouse
doesn't
move a lighthouse stands in one place
and gives direction to every
ship a lighthouse is not meant to align
with the ship's sales a ship is meant to
align its sales with the
lighthouse and which is precisely why
there are Lighthouse Universal
principles that can make the world a
better
place the more we are in alignment with
those principles the world will
definitely be a better place how many of
you would agree that if we were kinder
to each other and kinder to every
everybody in the world would be a better
place that's the lighthouse principle we
are called a
humankind and we should be a human and
we should be kind both that's why we
called a humankind how many of you would
agree that we were to be empathetic
sensitive to the needs of every person
in the world the world would be a better
place thank you how many of you would
agree that we were to harmonize on what
is common amongst all of us and not
focus on the differences all the time
the world would be a better
place thank you how many of you would
agree that if we were to come together
as one force and not divide ourselves
into multiple forces the world would be
a better place thank you the more we
align ourselves with the lighthouse
principles the world's going to be a
better place I want to just offer to you
three essential principles of
gratitude being mindful and
grateful the first one
being
recognizing
recognizing all the wonderful things
that have been done to us believe me you
we are in such a such a rush most of the
time we not even thoughtful and mindful
to recognize the incredible gifts that
have been showered upon
us how many of you had loving parents
most all of us how many how many of us
feel that we've been receiving so much
affection from our parents yes how many
of you have loving spouses you might
want to or may not want to raise your
hands that is completely up to you it's
your choice ladies and gentlemen whether
you want to raise your hands for
this how many of you had wonderful
teachers how many of you had some
amazing
friends great how many of you have come
in contact with some wonderful spiritual
personalities great great and how many
of us feel that our life is a collective
sum total of the so many wonderful
things that have been done to us by so
many in our lives show off hands please
all of us isn't it so many of us have
been recipients and received so much
from our families from our friends from
our teachers from Saints I'll tell you
something to be very honest what the
world needs
today is transformed into
individuals we have a lot of affluence
we have a lot of
influence we have a lot of
information we are in an age which is
Laden Laden with information you know
what we truly need is transformed
individuals who can utilize what we have
for constructive causes in the world who
can truly bring light to the world who
can truly bring hope to the world
there's enough information what we would
need is
transformation and what better
away but to have a spiritual
culture to bring that transformation in
individuals and in fact I don't want to
say it but I must that spirituality
happens to be one of those major ways to
bring transformation and individual
people I see so many people following
different parts of spirituality and
change and transform to not just be a
part of competition but be a part of
contribution along with competition
they're also looking at
contribution youth is the Hope For The
Wealth youngsters young men and ladies
are the ones who can change the shape of
planet Earth who can change the way the
world functions bringing an incredible
hope and light to the world because you
made it this far a video I want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you are
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible J shett motivation check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there and so I think when
we are guiding people or talking about
purpose we have to have very thoughtful
and mindful conversations around it now
if someone comes up to me and says Jay I
don't know what my purpose is can you
help me as you just put there I would
focus